so in like 2012 2013 2014 he started a
vitamin brand and it only did okay and
then he started also tinkering with a
skincare brand which it actually did
much better it got to like 10 million or
so in revenue he hired a ceo the ceo
kind of like drove it into the ground
and didn't really do that well so he
started focusing again to his vitamin
brand and he's like look it's doing okay
but
who's the best customer of a vitamin
company
dogs
because you and this is it i'm not
disparaging him but like
do they work
yeah why not
like fugazi you know like forget it
yeah forgot welcome to fugazi inc yeah
supplements for dogs they'll never tell
you if it works or doesn't work
[Music]
what up what up
are we supposed to like start with like
a
catchphrase now
hey boys and girls welcome to the
business show where you learn how to
make so much money that you'll get taxed
out the ass
that's what rich people care about taxes
if you don't care about taxes yet you
ain't rich do you care about taxes yeah
i like i don't i don't i'm not gonna
live my life according to like where the
low taxes are but like it's like the
number two or number three thing that
i'm thinking about so i'm thinking about
this whole new york texas thing and i
like do the math and i'm like
damn like imagine i gotta rent a place
for let's just say like 20 grand a month
like that's how much taxes i'm paying
by moving here versus staying or you
know whatever it is like a lot of money
a month
well you have a good thing you could do
the like texas as your main residence
and spend four or five months out of the
year in new york so that's not so bad
that's not so bad
but yeah i i need to do it with uh new
york and florida because texas winter is
not like winter winter that's desirable
enough that you want a winter there you
know what i mean
yeah yeah dude have you heard about this
like the teddy bear law the teddy bear
what's that
so i was asking my text guys i was like
where do you keep your like
possessions
yeah basically i was like so what's the
rule is it six months out of the year
what does it take to have residency in
some place and he was like
well it's there's a bunch of little
factors he's like but one he's like
there was a famous case with derek jeter
the the new york yankee shortstop
they're like
jeter wanted jeter played for the
yankees in new york but he didn't want
to pay new york taxes he wanted to pay
florida taxes because he's like look
this is my home this is where i live
blah blah blah but you also have an
apartment in new york and you play in
new york you say you work there
your home is there and your kids go to
school there i think there and so they
ended up it got uh ruled in in court and
they called i think the the the name
they call it as the i haven't looked
this up it's like the teddy bear law and
it's basically like where would you keep
your teddy bear so the place you would
call home so like factors like where
your kids go to school where are the
possessions that you love it all goes
into this like umbrella to be like where
do we actually think your home is and um
and actually when i first heard this i
was like wow that's really like
subjective for like a ruling or a law
and actually it's one of the laws i kind
of agree with i actually think that that
is more like how it should be done which
is like dude what's the spirit of this
do you actually live here or do you just
like stay here for exactly six months
and one day every year and i have to you
know i don't actually know where you are
at any given time but if you know if
you're working in a place your kids go
to school there all your possessions are
there all your friends are there your
family is there like that's where you
live as an avid listener of dateline one
of the easiest ways to catch the husband
who kills the wife is like three weeks
before he either bought like you know a
trash bag and like a shovel or he
googled like how to dispose of a body
and last night i found myself googling
and i was so embarrassed to do this so i
went to an incognito window i was like i
can't google this
yeah like they're gonna know that i
killed her yeah
and it was like how does
the state that you're visiting no like
like if i'm renting
and i don't even know what to google by
the way i was trying to figure out how
to phrase this but if i live in texas
how does new york even know that i'm
there if i'm just renting a place
dude you know so funny you said that i
did the same thing and like my queries
sound exactly like does the irish really
know it's like somehow somehow that's
how it's like formatted in my search
like so yeah like google would like to
understand dude google needs to
understand italicized really
like the asterisk and everything it's
like there's one browser that's just
like hmm this guy's only ever incognito
and he's either looking at porn or taxes
like what's this guy's life like right
because like basically it's like you
know i'm trying to google like
um
when you get you know
if the irs does this you is that like
jail or justified yeah
are we bringing a rule or a law
right is this are taxes a recommendation
or a requirement
well when i learned google this googling
this was the irs and i like it makes
sense but i didn't even understand it
irs is for federal so like uh but i pay
my federal taxes no matter what but i'm
like okay so then how does the state of
new york actually know that i was ever
here and i'm trying to like figure i
want to i'm googling that to follow the
rule but i am curious and i was going to
be clear in case they also listen to
podcasts i'm googling this a for a
friend and b
to enforce the law on my friend because
i'm not here for anything else and i was
just curious i'm just curious i'm like
literally how does the state of new york
even know that i exist
i'm the same way i i'm the same way
we're all go down this rabbit hole then
i'm like 30 minutes in i'm like why am i
even looking for this is not applicable
at all to me but i'm like i just want to
know how it works like i'll be like
when you keep the receipt does anybody
ever go read the receipts like you know
what what actually are like you know
there's this twitter account i love
called uh how stuff works or something
like that i love it and today they
posted a thing of like it was like
how luggage gets loaded into an airplane
so there's a guy in the back of the
airplane and then there's like a
conveyor belt shooting suitcases at him
and he's stacking it like a perfect
tetris grid
and i'm just like i do i love this
account because it's always these these
things where i'm like dude how does the
world actually work like i you know i
know i give them my suitcase but what
happens after that and it's like sort of
the same thing with like either taxes or
like
uh like all google just like you know
rich people don't pay taxes
but how like you know like what are
these loopholes that i hear about are
there are there really these loopholes
like are like you know universities have
this endowment
what the hell are they doing with that
and i'm just like always trying to get
to the bottom of like
i want to have like an actual
understanding of what's going on and
dude i feel like i have so little
understanding about so many things on
earth
but it's so funny that you you brought
that book i actually wrote i'm like
doing the thing with maven again the
ideation boot camp course and
uh i started talking about the book that
i had as a kid called how stuff works
and there's another one where they just
like split like a power tool into two
and you just see like a picture of like
how school bus like operates or whatever
and i'm like the reason why researching
which is what you and i do for this
podcast is cool is because whether you
like it or not america and the rest of
the most of the world is you know guided
by capitalism and commerce and so like
if you understand how like a business
works just like these books show you how
like the luggage guy works then you kind
of understand like what's possible and
what's not possible why laws are the way
they are why art is the way it is like
you can you it's not just money making
but it's just like the earth like just
how the world and society and so uh i
actually was just writing that yesterday
and
i totally agree and i think that's why i
like studying businesses is cool
and by the way like i think most people
do this for science they're like you
know why is the sky blue and like there
is an element of that i'm talking about
just like
here's a perfect example we'll use the
luggage one for example it's like
question
what happens if you just never pick up
your suitcase or like what happens if
you just simply like i see those bags
over there that say that they're waiting
for someone to come get them what
happens if they don't like is this just
gonna pile up forever you want to know
about the name of dr mario and then yeah
i do know
yeah i'll tee it up for you then there
is an answer and it's actually kind of
fascinating for somebody who goes and
digs in and says like okay but then what
right or like that you know like a kid
like well why do they do that and why do
they do that and why do they do that and
then you get to what's it called
unclaimed baggage or whatever it's
called like that what's that was that
the name of our company so basically the
hustle wrote about it so if you go like
the hustle unclaimed baggage there's a
company in like rural alabama i think
it's alabama or arkansas called
unclaimed baggage and they sell 300
million dollars a year worth of
unclaimed bags and they it's like a huge
thrift store you know right and uh
same thing with like the uh
like you know the shampoo at a hotel
like you know i use this thing once what
do they do with it do they just refill
it and give it to the next person i'm
curious what are they like oh actually
there's a whole company that recycles
these they take the half-used shampoos
from hotels and they say they tell the
hotel hey we'll pay you nothing for it
but we'll come collect it for you we'll
take it off your hands because you can't
give that to the next guest and then
they take that and then they have like
basically a way to repackage and resell
those and their brand is around
lessening waste on earth and they that
company does extremely well and so you
actually find companies at the end of
all these because again
this is like a giant little business
ecosystem just in the same way that like
you know there's plankton that eats
stuff off the whale's head or whatever
it's like you know basically there's a
little business that's going to solve
every one of these edge cases all around
the world right there's a person whose
job it is to do that thing and if you
keep going far enough you'll like find
those those little nooks and crannies
well which is a perfect segment for what
i want to talk about today because
here's here's what i i wanna i'm gonna
give you a bunch of example of things
that i've i'm calling frame breaking
businesses so like things that i've
discovered that have changed how i
thought about stuff and there's a story
uh
and by the way today i was i was
thinking i was like today's my leg day
because i'm putting you on my back and
i'm carrying us for this episode i i i
i've got a i've got like a side note by
the way my mom yesterday while i work
out with my mom sometimes and she was
like
sam parr's legs she always calls you sam
parr full name i love it i don't know if
she knows that's like your first and
last but
samparas legs man he's got strong legs
and i was like yeah he's great and she's
like i was just looking at his legs in
the last video the mr beast video
because you were wearing like shorts on
the couch or whatever i was just looking
at his legs i didn't hear anything
all right mom
hey uh shawn's mom text me i'll send you
some more pics and i'll send you some
pictures of my legs i got you
it's it's genetics so people people
comment on my legs it's just it was i
was born that way so thank you i
appreciate the love though um all right
so basically the reason i thought about
this was because
uh dig so there's this website called
dig it's actually not that popular
anymore but if you're above 30 you
probably know it digg and reddit were
competitors and for a long time dig was
kind of beating reddit but they were
both like the whole like front page of
the internet type of businesses that had
like
tens of millions of monthly uniques and
kevin rose the founder of digg was on
the cover of time as like meet silicon
valley's new wunderkind the guy who is
28 years old and worth a billion dollars
or whatever he was like the mark
zuckerberg like the next zugerberg and
dig ended up not actually winning this
battle and they're currently for sale
and i linked to their financials someone
just sent this to me on twitter so it's
not like i got this through um like i
didn't like sign up for a service where
i had to agree to confidentiality but
someone just sent this to me right you
signed an fda a full disclosure
agreement where you're like i will put
this on blast if you send this random
[__] to me yes an anonymous twitter
account that's exactly what happened
someone just said it to me i didn't ask
questions and i just looked at it but
i'll give you like the overview the
overview is that over the last year they
had 27 million users so what's that two
million a month so two which is not a
lot the hustle gets more than two
million a month just on our website and
we don't even try to get traffic on our
website so two million a month they're
revenue slam slam on dig nice it keep
going
they're okay so
their revenue for the year
was something like
a million or like 1.3 or like it was
like 1.2 1.3 nothing [__]
dig which was supposed to be like you
know a great website only like uh
80 70 91 000 44 000 a month in revenue
horrible
crazy terrified small boy [__] yeah yeah
and
but here's the thing is that this rep
this this discrepancy we're gonna call
it the gap the gap between how much we
talked about them and their prestige and
like you know the accolades that they
get as but from but the
the gap between where they actually are
in reality that gap is huge so instead
i'm gonna swap it and we're gonna have
some frame breaking companies and we're
gonna talk about the actual good type of
gap um and i want to show you a few
businesses that people don't talk about
that are actually phenomenal and really
interesting so i'm going to give you the
first one the first one i we maybe
talked about before but
i was uh
looking at michael bisping michael
bishing's a youtuber for mma and a vpn
company sponsored him and i thought
that's kind of strange so i just googled
like what's a good vpn and maybe i'll
start buying a vpn basically a vpn if
you're in america and you want to like
tell the internet that you're in europe
you use a vpn or if you're in like north
korea or one of the koreas whichever one
would this would apply to and you want
to act like you're in america you use a
vpn that's a that's a or if you just
want to like just search the web
anonymously and you want to google stuff
about taxes um and that's what the vpn
is for and so
i googled best
vpn and i came across this website
called compare tech that was kind of
intriguing so i linked to it you see
vpn
so i started reading it and i was like
this is kind of an interesting site and
i looked them up on similar web and they
get millions of views and i scroll all
the way to the bottom and i notice that
they're based in england
and the thing about england and the uk
is that if you are a uk company
name all the things you love about about
england uh maybe the t
maybe you like the queen and you like
the fact that all companies numbers are
publicly available yes a lot of people
don't know this but if you are a company
in the uk i don't know what the
threshold is it could be as low as five
it could be as high as 10 million and
you do over 10 million in revenue you
have to there's this thing called
companies house which is a very british
name it's like they're i don't know if
it's like is it like they're
irs or something like that where you can
go and log in and see all these
financials
from privately held companies and i was
curious about this little website called
compare tech so i went and looked it up
on their on company's house
can you see what their financials are do
you have it up i don't have it open no
okay so i'm gonna pull it up and i i
linked to it down there it said
financials um basically oh [__]
it the link broke on me but basically
their revenue
for the trailing 12 months was 12
million
and their profit was 10 million
and this little website
that just reviews vpns it's i'm sure
it's more sophisticated than what it
looks like but it's not good looking
it's not like
uh doesn't have like the best design and
i believe this website ended up selling
for like 200 million dollars and i think
it only gets like a million visits a
month it sold uh
last year
or six six or 10 six or 12 months ago
interesting site right
that's crazy it was also only started in
2015. so sometimes i see these sites
that i'm like oh wow this thing gets so
much traffic and they just send clicks
out to whatever basically their business
model is
they write about which vpn to use and
then they link you to the vpn and they
get a kickback from any whichever link
you click of the 10
they'll get a kickback from all 10 for
you know some some dollar value right if
the vpn says
cool every customer's worth 300 dollars
to us we'll pay a hundred dollars to
anybody that refers as a customer and so
these guys will do you know some numbers
like that
normally when i see those like really
high traffic uh sites that sort of just
look very basic it's like you know this
was started in 2004. i'm like well
okay props to you you had the foresight
to know that like very early on in like
the you know the internet days or
google's days somebody was like i'm
gonna start reviewing credit cards i'm
gonna start reviewing vpn providers i'm
gonna start reviewing what email
software is best and they made what
email software is best.com and like you
know that they rake in
six million dollars a year you know uh
ninety percent profit margin something
silly like that and like you know the
person is spent the last 15 years trying
to figure out you know the meaning of
life because they won the business game
already and so that's normally what you
see but 2015 is like pretty new for a
site like this it's pretty new and here
here's their financials i went and found
them on companies house in 2021 they did
15 million in revenue
and 13.2 million in profit the year
before that 10 million in revenue 9.5
million in profit
that's crazy this is crazy right
right
yeah i i'm a big fan of these now by the
way do you ever do you play with seo a
lot because
um
growth tactics
are like martial arts it's like you
could be a black belt in jiu jitsu and
know nothing about karate right or you
know karate and you know nothing about
taekwondo or judo you don't know how to
do any grappling and any throws
and that's how i feel about growth
channels it's like i've spent a lot of
my career figuring out virality spent a
lot of my career figuring out paid
marketing now with e-commerce things
like that uh the thing i've never
touched is seo dude i know i'm like
absolute novice on it absolutely i know
seo like an ivy league architect knows
about construction like maybe i can have
a conversation with the construction
worker who's going to build my project
and like kind of know but like i'm not
going to be able to reference like which
rivet to use and you could kind of lie
to me sometimes and i wouldn't exactly
know if you were right
right right you put me on the job site
and um i'm gonna ask for some gloves
because i don't yeah i don't wanna hurt
my hands
yeah i'm just gonna everything's gonna
be called a monkey wrench so like i
don't entirely understand seo but i do
believe
it's the maybe the best one uh like it's
like like if you nail it i think it's
the best thing to nail or one like that
that seed in the office when dwight's
like uh you know trying to ignore jim
and then jim's like dwight are they
they're doing like a job interview
which bear is best
he's like that's a stupid question
there's and he's like
basically
yeah
well there's basically two schools of
thoughts here wrong yeah
that's that's how i feel about like you
know is seo best was like i don't know
is brown bear best or is it black bear
best right like every
every one of these growth channels is
like has something awesome and then
something terrible and the one you're in
you know it too well usually and you're
like this thing is awful i wish i could
just go on facebook and spend money and
get two more spend a dollar get two
dollars back and the facebook guy's like
oh my god you can get free traffic on
google and the google guy's like holy
[__] this thing grows virally wow what
is that you know and so i think there's
no there's no best
i yeah i would agree but and by the way
this site comparetech it was sold for uh
yeah it was sold for over
a hundred million dollars i believe this
year in 2022
um for like one figure give me give me
another frame breaker that's a great
first one all right another one a
company can i give a ps here just in
case something good happens a ps is
uh with the milk road today we run our
like our business model is newsletter
ads and i had asked ben i was like ben
if we were going to sell a product our
own product instead of
advertise other people's products what
would be what product would work best
what bear is best ben and he was like
vpn dude
he's like we should just launch our own
vpn uh fits the audience you gotta come
up with an amazing business model we
just have to buy an existing vpn and
plug in our distribution and so if
anyone has a vpn they want to sell me
i'm happy to either buy one or build our
own yeah you gotta come up with like
some cute branding like vpnope you know
what i mean like you can't track me you
know like you gotta come up with
something cute just like you do with
milk roads i think we gotta just get get
rid of vpn that's just two whatever it
needs to be like you know
whatever mysterio or like you know some
like you know
you know secret juice and it's like ah i
use secret juice
i'm on board with this don't tell don't
tell you know yeah just call it don't
tell mom uh all right the next one quinn
street have you heard of quint street
um no
all right google quinn street and go to
their website for me
all right i'm gone
and tell me like what my guess is i
thought this was a fashion brand if you
told me nothing else but okay i'm
guessing it's not all right quinn street
i just see a guy and it says where
performance drives digital and then
there's like another stock photo and
this guy accessing high intent prospects
this guy's a horrible stock mod like
these guys on here aren't ugly enough to
be like a stock model they're not good
looking enough to be
like they look like they're like out of
like a like spanish or
like geometry telemundo yeah like they
just look like just normal
you know it's like it's they're so
normal that they don't even look why
does your skin have like you know
normal people wrinkles and blemishes
that's not right stock photo you need to
be perfectly airbrushed right is this
the founder it looks like the founder i
don't know i don't know who the founder
is but it's like a simple ass website
that's not good looking
all right
dude i'm going through the slideshow
this slideshow is hilarious dude this
looks like you know meredith from the
office this is like that's what i'm
saying they're like so normal
that they're not
that it looks silly so this this company
i'm gonna explain what they do i'm gonna
tell you how big they are so what this
company does is they used to own and i
don't know if they still own these sites
but i'll tell you what they what they
still own now but they used to own
websites like
directoryofschools.com or
campuscorner.com
or learningandlife.com or
findtherightschool.com
just like these like boring websites
that don't look that cool and when you
google ohio insurance
ohio auto insurance they come up number
one you enter an information and they
sell that information to the highest
bidder for insurance people this website
it's like ugly looking it's simple
looking and you like a lot of people
disrespect it
they made about 600 million in revenue
last year it's publicly traded it's
publicly traded
that's crazy right this is this is
another frame breaking company like they
have
if you click their about page on queen
street they're about or one of their
forms like it doesn't work like it's
like it goes to like a 401 like it they
don't have it set up
dude okay you know when you meet someone
and you're like i can't tell if this
person is absolutely a genius
or if they're completely idiotic or if
you're in san francisco you see somebody
walking to a fancy restaurant with like
a hoodie and like you know they're like
wearing one all bird and one croc and
you're like all right this person's
either homeless or a billionaire right
like that's like a pretty common
situation in san francisco that's how i
feel when i go to websites like this i'm
like
these are either the biggest dummies on
earth and don't because i can't i can't
understand what they do right their
website is full of pages it just says
like performance are our products or
something yeah it's like going into a
video game and like you talk you bump
into one of the stock characters that
just like it's like oh hey didn't see
you there hello and this is that keeps
repeating on loop some random [__] that
doesn't make any sense that's their
website so these websites they're either
like absolute money printers
or it's like you know someone's aunt
who's got some dream of like you know
being successful and they're never gonna
make it because this makes no sense i
can't tell and now when i get to finally
then i see the key money tab investor
relations if you got an investor
relations tab on your on your website
like it's working right like you know
put in the bill clinton clip where he's
like i did not have relations with that
woman that's how that's how i feel when
i see the investor relations tab i know
some shit's going down that's hilarious
our software is the worst have you heard
of hubspot see most crms are a cobble
together mess but hubspot is easy to
adopt and actually looks gorgeous i
think i love our new crm our software is
the best hubspot grow better
it's kind of this whole website and this
whole brand it reminds me of like a
fourth grade classroom with like the uh
like you know like teamwork and like
each letter like it spells a certain
word do you know what i mean or like
teamwork t is for teamwork
these are everybody
that's what the this whole website looks
like but it makes 500 600 ish million in
revenue market cap isn't very great
because it's a uh legion company those
typically just don't have good market
caps but it's just crazy they just
ignored all the unimportant stuff like
how good does their uh website their
like uh
public-facing brand website look and
they only focus on just the results i
guess and they own all these other
websites that don't look so bad and they
clearly get results but it's like a
really interesting company and it's
another frame breaking business where
they just don't give a [__] about the
things that most people care about and
it works it's effective so i recently
met two guys who
run a business like this
and they've run three other businesses
like this and exited them
i'm gonna share i can't share the story
now but i'm hoping
one month from today
i could share a kind of crazy story
about them so i'm just going to put that
there
crazy a teaser for a future one month
from today you know there will be a
crazy story about these two guys um i
might even have them on the podcast i
don't know yet but um but this is this
is insane this is a sample special how
did you find quinn street where where
were you
what was in the what vpn and private
browser did you have open when you were
searching for this two ways one a guy
named jackie chu who uh i like just like
tweeted
at this uh tweeted me this a while ago
and i just saved it and then number two
joe spicer my partner and a bunch of
stuff he told me he used to work with
them he owned an ad network and he was
like in the early 2000s like i worked
with them they basically right now they
do car insurance and things like that
but they used to do university of
phoenix so university of phoenix you
they would you know they owned all these
school websites you would google like
what's a good online degree they figured
out that and this what what the the
these guys look unsophisticated they are
not they're very sophisticated they like
know how to get traffic to websites they
know how to do seo like they look like a
fat guy who like it trains jiu jitsu
just like just like you talked about
like oh this guy he's good and but then
he like you know can like put you in a
headlock but in three seconds that's
what these guys are
uh and so anyway uh i found it just by
goofing around and talking to people
this is crazy so they own insurance.com
insurer.com car insurance.com
cardratings.com money rates bank tracker
m1 and modernize home services and then
they partner with way more
by the way that's a really great source
for info is talk to people at ad
networks yeah they know every people who
like work at google cloud or aws they
know everything they see everything they
they know who's making money and who's
not they know uh who's getting traffic
and who's not and uh like if you ever
wanted to go figure out your next gig
go be like uh yeah i'll be janitor at
this like mobile ad network or i'm gonna
go be janitor at aws
uh my payment all i need is like login
credentials into the dashboard i'd like
to i'll be a account rep for high value
clients and therefore i need that list
of the high value accounts that we have
and you basically just mine that and
you're like all right
which one of these you know
who am i going to copy
dude there's a website like going
through it going to a barber shop and
you see like
i'll take the number 12
the [__] boy fade please yeah the line
on the side exactly like that please do
you guys do eyebrow lightning bolts no
yeah okay fine i'll take the number
twelve then
that's so funny
dude all right the next one
is in your world
not just
because he's an indian guy
but because
[Music]
he's he's an e-commerce guy for some
reason come up with some reason that
it's not just that
i don't know man indian entrepreneurs
you guys are taking over the world i'm
sure you guys all are part of the same
tribe you know one another kinda there's
only a billion of you um so this guy all
right so i was looking at the inc 5000
list of all the lists that's the only
one that like kind of matters it's still
you could still game really dude i see
this all the time i see the random ass
some digital agency that i've worked
with that does not like nothing special
they're like we're a three-time inc 5000
winner i'm like well you guys are based
off of you could still it's supposed to
be based on revenue and they're suppose
so i don't trust inc anymore but i used
to and when i did like
i clicked the link for 2022 block fi is
number one block five basically just
went out of business like three months
ago so i think that tells me everything
i need to know
in your goddamn
they had already written the story
though
the greatest active athletes bill
russell like he just passed away two
weeks ago
they like created the list and someone
who works here like hey uh we gotta
remove block five from number one and
they're like
huh seems like a lot of work they're
like
look
i don't make up the rules here i just
think them up and write that down
according to us is
245 000
this year
it's like yeah
you forgot the negative sign dude
like but it's like it's so far away the
computer
i don't know where my charger is
that's what the 85 000 is to go to the
office
no
[Laughter]
i guess i could swing my best buy on my
way home yeah but they're like oh it's
happy hour daiquiri have you ever been
at a uh have you ever been at like your
company happy hour and like you'll hear
news that something really really bad
has happened and had you heard about
that during the day you'd be like livid
i'm gonna act on this yeah i'm gonna
[__] kill someone like this is livid
and then you hear about it like when
you're laughing at happy or you're like
huh
yeah and like
that's like what happened you know what
i'm talking about you're a bit like a
company happy how do you like hear bad
news and you're like 100. we used to do
ours on friday it was called the friday
wind down and it was like wine and
cheese and like whatever you know that
often you guys posh
seems like a wine and cheese types of
guy though like i know but the office
before i joined the office was pretty
you know adult and mature and like
sophisticated people and then i joined i
started hiring people that would sleep
at the office and so like it became this
crazy culture clash we ended up ending
it but
it was so funny because it would be like
friday you look at the numbers like well
still don't have product market fit i
guess all right let's just head over to
the office bar and just drink for a bit
like
servers downs like how much traffic you
think we get on the weekends anyways
yeah one guy would go back to his desk
to like fix the thing or like check they
checked their email like oh we gotta go
fix this and then everybody else would
be like
sort of watch them walk away be like all
right if he looks like he's having
trouble i'll go too
like no don't
that's how you talk it's just the voice
of like well let me know if you need
anything
which apparently just [__] black but
i didn't really i saw black pepper one i
didn't realize that that was the company
that like went out of business with so
yeah the list is kind of null at this
point it doesn't really matter but
i saw someone who's number six or number
seven it's called high key it's like a
keto cookie business type of thing and
the la the guy's last name i don't know
if it says it on this list but this
other list i was looking at it was patel
and they used his real name but i was
like wait i think that sounds like aj
patel so who i recognize and high key
was like six or five do you see what it
is on the list
yeah it's number five or six yeah and
they grew by forty
one thousand percent i think that just
means 41 x right so like if it was a
million they do 42 million now or 41
million yeah again these numbers
by the way my favorite word
have you ever heard this word yeah it
just means like uh fake right
yeah but i'm i'm all about the word
fugazi i feel like i can own this corner
i don't know anyone who says it and
absolute pleasure absolutely treat to
say the same yeah
it's like well it's like the most
popular line in uh wolf of wall street
yeah it goes it's all good you know just
carry the 12 you know like i just can't
do this
so this guy uh aj patel he started this
thing called high key which i would
imagine is in the 30 or 40 million range
but listen to this guy so he's probably
in his
later 30s probably 35 or 36 so in like
2012 2013 2014 he started a vitamin
brand and it only did okay and then he
started also tinkering with a skin care
brand which it actually did much better
it got to like 10 million or so in
revenue he hired a ceo the ceo kind of
like drove it into the ground and didn't
really do that well and so he started
focusing again to his vitamin brand and
he's like look it's doing okay
but
who's the best customer of a vitamin
company
dogs
[Laughter]
because
this is a i'm not disparaging him but
like
do they work
yeah why not like fugazi you know like
forget it yeah forgot welcome to fugazi
inc yeah supplements for dogs they'll
never tell you if it works or doesn't
work
yeah you know
it's like uh it's like uh what's that
memory loss game uh where it's like
brain teasers you know brain dacity or
brain acid yeah it's called it's like
it's like neuroscience yeah it's like
having like like a like a like an ad
campaign towards those with amnesia like
or or with like alzheimer's like does it
work
yeah maybe uh so that's like what what
like these vitamins for dogs are like
who knows if it actually works and
he starts growing this company pivots
from like you know normal vitamins to
dog vitamins and he starts growing this
thing and it takes off after a while and
any kills it he gets a 25 million in
revenue and then he sells part of it uh
to a pe company and he took 60 million
off the table then he grew for another
three years and sold it for like 650
million dollars and he still owned like
half of it so collectively he made 300
400 million dollars at the age of 32 and
this guy isn't in silicon valley he's
not in new york he's not in brooklyn
he's in
orlando florida capital of jorts short
city usa
you know george city white new balance
town
22 listeners in orlando they all just
collectively looked down at their lap
came back and nodded like uh the fact's
a fact baby
yeah yeah yeah like
like you know the england or illinois is
the land of lincoln florida's like land
of dog the bounty hunter you know like
and that's where this this he's born in
india indian immigrant came over decided
for some reason
florida's the place and
knocked it out the park and
not really well known and i was just
like researching him and
high key
is now
number six on this list they grew 41
41 000 so 41 x so if they were doing a
million in revenue or 500 000 in revenue
they're doing 20 to 40 million in
revenue now so it's another nine figure
in value brand and this guy's just
quietly crushing it and i love it and i
watched a talk with him
uh there's this thing there's this
website called capitalism.com dude i'm
reading the transcript of that talk
right now as you speak it's pretty crazy
so so let me just recap this guy's known
mostly for he sold zesty paws that that
company for 600 million i think right so
the page it was over in the in the in
the transcript he says yeah the public
number is 600 but it actually got raised
uh a little bit higher wow and he um he
also has high key snacks
in this thing it says his first business
uh like his first kind of side hustle
was he was selling he's like i played
single poker and i got to a mill by the
way i did this exact same thing that's
why this stood out to me i told you you
guys are brothers man you guys are yeah
now i know the connection so he got to a
million chips he sold it for 37 bucks i
i did this on poker stars i grinded my
way i got i accumulated a million that
was my actual first million
it was a million fake poker chips on
poker stars and i sold it for 13
and i tell you what i've never felt like
more of a prostitute in my life i was
like wow i just worked so hard
for like three months to get you know
like just grinding the free money game
and i got to a million chips and i sold
it for 13 via paypal
and then i proceeded to lose the 13
immediately on the real money tables and
i was like i never felt like you know
you should
take a shower i just i feel dirty yeah i
googled like can i declare bankruptcy
just out of embarrassment like you know
is there is there some like version of
that because i was so embarrassed at
like the the terrible trade i had done
he said he did that same thing and he
started doing that as a like as a market
basically on ebay i think he made like
100 or 200 grand
just doing the
fake poker chips like buying and selling
basically
which is it's kind of like uh
you know it's kind of like a a kid being
good at chess when they're six like if
you're doing that on ebay it's like yeah
you're gonna yeah well just here's all
my money just hopefully you'll figure it
out one day just get me back when you
can like that's what you do when you
when you meet people doing things like
that that's like just
we need this guy on uh and i'll give you
i'm talking to him i've been talking to
him on facebook i got him
he's he clearly has
you know he comes from our he's cut from
the same uh the same cloth i don't know
what what kind of cloth that is but but
it's definitely our cloth
we'll assume it's silk
but dude this guy he
i started becoming friends with him on
facebook never talked to in my life
there's a software that i needed to use
i don't want to out them but there's a
software i needed to use and it's like
10 grand a year and i mentioned to him
that i use it he goes oh here i have an
annual subscription here's my password
and he's been letting me use his free
like 10 000 a year subscription so this
guy this guy is my guy i'm mad yeah yeah
and so wait what's the second reason why
why we need him on here because i just
googled his name aj patel
now here's a guy sold a company for over
600 million sold another company he's
got high key snacks you know he's
sitting on store shelves everywhere
across the country
guess what google puts up in the the
like google thinks i'm talking about
patel aj md the doctor in san francisco
dude no matter what an indian guy does
in business the doctor is still number
one he's still at the top of the ranks
so he needs to come on this pod so we
can we can get this guy's seo but it's
like
one what's uh jessica alba's company
honest the guy who started that his name
is brian lee he started like that shoe
dazzle and like legal zoom if you google
brian lee like he ain't coming up oh
dude it's uh a wrestler it's a it's a
guy who looks like undertaker or like a
big show or something yeah like brian
lee like it doesn't matter if you're a
billionaire or not you you know you you
can't
which by the way fame is always way
better than than money so
wrestling wrestling beats being a
billionaire but this guy in his talk he
said something amazing so like he hired
the ceo to run his skincare brand and he
says yeah like it's stunk this guy like
i gave him the reins and i told him to
do it and he totally talked slick to me
and i thought he knew what he was doing
and he and it didn't work and the guy
goes uh
the interviewer goes well was it a sad
day when you fired him like he must have
been hard right and aj goes no it was
awesome firing him was so easy because
he was so bad and i felt so great like
getting rid of all the dead weight and i
look at business as a living organism
and like i have zero emotional
attachment if someone doesn't serve the
business and i'm willing to fire myself
or anyone else and i have zero sadness
about it and i saw that and i was like
hell yeah i call that you know what i
call that i call that korean convenience
store owner energy remember you remember
here's why you remember um
during remember like the rodney king
riots like in the 90s remember like
these pictures of like the korean store
business owners with like shotguns
standing on top of their like they're
like no we like yeah like let's go
i was talking to like some people i
invested in the other day and they were
telling me about their business and like
how they're like things aren't going
that well i'm like well can you do me a
favor like do a screen share let me see
your calendar
and like it was totally open and like
they hadn't booked a lot like i'm like
what i'm like morning meditation
afternoon walk
yeah i'm like dude from 8 00 a.m to 8
p.m it's gotta you have to have sales
calls set up with prospective customers
and like don't give me this nonsense of
like oh well you know it went out of
business but we learned a lot or like
you know like we just couldn't
or the things that you're suggesting sam
they don't scale i'm like no no no dude
right now you need to have that korean
store owner
energy where it's just like if you don't
make this work you don't feed your
family and maybe you're gonna get
deported like you need to have that like
like
that that energy of like starvation with
a side of deportation is how sam likes
his dish is served dude
you have to have that energy sometimes
like of course like once things going
well yeah you got to get like beyond
like scale and all that stuff but like
early on call yourself a startup call
yourself
it didn't matter what you call yourself
you're just a convenience store owner
and like some convenience stores you go
there and they have every type of kind
bar you could ever imagine that's where
i'm going other type of convenience
stores like you know they don't have
what i want i ain't ever going there
again you got to be that convenience
store that has every kind bar every
cliff bar has a stick and it's just
grinding and knows your name they are
willing to call me like you know like
what do you want the usual that type of
that's what like a lot of startup uh
founders need and so uh this guy aj
patel he's got that korean store
business owner energy you know that like
immigrant hustle i love it
yeah he's great and that's great and i
feel like we know so many people
that it's like i meet with them and i
hear them talking and it's like oh let's
just fast forward to the part where you
write a medium article called my next
chapter or our next our next adventure
and then you're gonna sign off saying
onwards
yeah like you're a [__] captain of a
ship in the 1700s like
ahoy matey your business is failing wake
up
do something don't just sit there and
lose and then go work at facebook and
write my next chapter i'm so excited to
lead you know you know digital digital
ad products at facebook now for the next
two years of my life before i go out and
do this same stupid thing again it's
like wake up go figure this out right
figure out something that's going to
work i don't care what you do i don't
even care if it's bad but like i need to
see some like some serious action being
taken you know and like realize your
[__] is not working
and like i invest in startups and i know
that the name of the game is you're
going to lose most your money and only a
few are going to like return all the
money but when i hear like their updates
i'm like all right
i i'm okay with swinging and missing i'm
not actually okay with it but i know
that's part of the game and it's just a
numbers game but for those not swinging
it doesn't matter if i only invested
five thousand dollars i reply and i'm
like oh you're losing and you suck for
these reasons and you need to improve
because i give you my hard-earned money
so you can have a good shot at trying
something and you are not trying or
taking a good shot and that's pissing me
off and i told some of my other angel
investor friends and like well i kind of
feel that way but i never say that like
what do you like what what why not
why wouldn't you say this it doesn't
matter how little or how much you
invested you gave your hard-earned money
to someone to like take a swing
step to the plate dog like swing but
don't like give me this nonsense
we um
uh we have this phrase i use in all my
companies which is that
all right people are going to make
mistakes but there's two types of
mistakes and you have to you have to
decide when you when you make a mistake
which one is it did you make an error of
action or an error of inaction
an error of action is you tried
something and you did it wrong or it
didn't work or had a bad result but you
you know you were trying really hard to
do something and you just messed it up
that's okay that's a fumble no problem
then there's an error of inaction which
is your mistake was that you didn't do
something you didn't think about
something you didn't anticipate it you
didn't plan
you know you just forgot to do something
you dropped the ball and that's the
unforgivable one right so it's like
i'm always like number one to be like
bro no problem this was an error of
action that's great i love errors of
action that's how you get better and
like never feel bad or sorry for an
error of action for an error of inaction
i now have a problem and so i feel the
same way with founders that i invest in
it's like
some of them i'm like oh man they're
just banging their head against this
wall
i will only ever say something to
somebody if i feel like if it's if
they're making errors of action when
they're making errors of inaction my
experience i did it twice now and i was
just like hey guys
like you're like your update makes it
sounds like everything's okay but like
read what you said everything is not
okay and like you got to do something
what could we do here and i like rolled
up my sleeves and i was like helping
them with their strategy and their pivot
and then their investor deck to raise
money because they're running out of
money and same thing with the other one
i was like hey guys like this is just
not working like you don't have product
market fit you have like two customers
after two years like what's going on and
they're like no we're really excited
about the pipeline we think that that
doesn't that's not fair
and i was just like oh my god
not only were you like not aware of it
you're actually in denial of it uh wow
this is like you know complete waste of
my time and
you know sure enough in both cases they
you know
my like several days worth of like
full-time effort to try to help them uh
resulted in nothing and so you know i
now i'm picking i'm a little bit pickier
where i'll test the waters and i'll see
does this person if given a dose of
reality do they take it and say more
please or are they like oh i don't want
this and it's like oh if you don't want
reality then i don't want to you know i
was just it was a mistake on my part i
judged wrong you know
my my check was written to the wrong
person here as the great dr phil once
said don't piss on my back and tell me
it's rain
all right i got one last one um
i have an interesting one so it's like a
billy of the week but someone who like
people never talk about or at least they
don't talk about a lot and he's got that
gap and when i say he it's actually him
and his wife and his wife is actually
the more interesting person but uh this
guy a little bit is more front-facing
his name's stuart resnick have you ever
heard of stuart resnick you know have we
talked about him
i don't know the name but i just googled
it and now i know they do the the
wonderful company or whatever so so give
me his story all right so listen to this
guy his name's stuart resnick him and
his wife his wife's name is linda
they're based out of california and so
in the 1970s he started a janitor
business and he just basically like was
a janitor at one point i think and then
he eventually hired a few more and he
got contracts with buildings and once he
was in those buildings and had the
contracts he expanded to uh security
guards and at one point he had a
thousand armed security guards on staff
so he like drew this janitor business
into a security guard business and it
was amazing he got some lucrative
contracts to uh lax and it turned out to
be a great business and he ended up
selling it and he made a little bit of
money and with that money he eventually
bought the franklin mint which at the
time was one of the world's largest
sellers of
uh
coins collectible coins and oddly enough
you know who owns the franklin mitt
right now
no no idea former mfm
tai lopez does he really
yeah that was my that was a joke yeah
basically a good job so basically like
in the 60s 70s 80s and even up into the
90s like all the marilyn monroe coins
and elvis presley coins the franklin
mint they uh they're the ones who uh
started it or uh who produced a lot of
them and so from there he parlayed that
to a couple of things and now at this
point his company it's called uh
wonderful brands they own a bunch of
really interesting brands they own
landmark wines that's not that
interesting teleflora you know what
teleflora is it's a pretty big 350
million dollar a year business where you
call it's like 1-800 flowers a
competitor but here's the big ones that
they own the first is wonderful
pistachios you've seen those at the
store right
the second is palm wonderful you know
palm wonderful yeah palm juice yeah
pomegranate yeah palm juice and so
basically the wife linda she uh she's
like you know i love pomegranates but
there's no this was like in the in the
80s she's like there's not really a good
pomegranate juice let's let's do this
juice and she goes you know what uh
pomegranate it's good for your heart
it's uh what else is it and she like
learns about what it's good for and she
was like you know it makes women have
like an hour glass figure like it like
is like good for you and like it's you
know it makes you feel good i guess and
so they made she made the bottle like a
you know it's like if you ever seen it
it's like a signature bottle yeah yeah
it's like a signature bottle well they
own another company that has a wonderful
signature bottle called
fiji water
so they they also own fiji which has a
square bottle and at this point they're
privately owned they're one of the
largest producers of uh one of the
largest farm owners in america so they
own uh almond and pistachio farms and
they do four billion dollars a year in
revenue and so it says in 2018 they were
the wealthiest farmers in the country
yeah and this guy
there you know the the i believe the the
wife linda she's jewish but she's got
this like southern belle charm to her
like she's from like alabama or
something she might be like an old like
you know faulkner novel like she reminds
me of like a character in force gump
movie and
and but they're based out of california
and then he's got like a little new york
vibe where he like kind of comes off as
like cool and hip but they're farmers
they own they're huge farmers and
they're like have the best
brands out there fiji is a great brand
and they created these they're not just
acquiring these right no they made them
yeah they make these brands and they own
way more wonderful is a really good
brand i love wonderful pistachios and so
these guys just kill it they're just
quietly crushing it and i think at this
point i think they're like 81 or 82
years old and i still watch talks with
them and they talk about how they go
well how do you stay close to their
customers and they're like well i just
read twitter all day and i like read
about and like sometimes
they're just like us yeah they're just
like us
and so sometimes they they just like
look at like what customers they're like
we use facebook and we just like skim
like our page and we just see like which
complaints are actually good and which
are are nonsense and we reply then we
make changes and we just run our
business that way and they're really
interesting people so that's the billy's
of the week stuart resnick and his wife
linda linda
wow yeah she looks like the type person
that would give you a kiss on the cheek
and then wipe off the lipstick
what just happened
yeah yeah
i love those women they always smell so
good yeah yeah
like going to the bathroom at one of the
at a woman like that's house it's just
an absolute pleasure there's so many
things you need to know so many cents
since you didn't even know existed like
you'll spend 15 minutes just trying to
wash your hands to get out of there
because it's like oh wow this
this is like a handkerchief instead of
like a towel this is amazing yeah at the
end of this you're gonna be an expert on
butterscotch candy like you're gonna
know all about like those little like
red green and yellow candies that like
what the [__] what are these things it's
like
fruit punch candies uh so i love this
brand um this is amazing and by the way
this teleflora 1-800 flowers thing why
doesn't somebody create
like 1-800 flowers to tell the floor
flowers as just a ghost kitchen on
doordash and on ubereats like why is
this does that exist like what why can't
i just order flowers i've seen a flower
thing when i go on there but i think
it's like doordash's own i think you
could create like either edible and
rainbows
or a flower thing and just partner with
local florists to fulfill the demand um
and it's like it's like way better than
food but uh i know whenever there's like
a birthday or something like that that's
my go-to thing now it's just like i'm
gonna doordash them something right
because it's like i never planned
some what's like a good enough like i'll
do like like the last one i did was like
you know like a a bunch of boba tea like
this person like really likes boba teas
so i sent them a bunch of boba or i'll
send them like you know uh pizza and
wings or i'll send them a cinnabon and
whatever or i'll send them you know a
bunch of ice cream or chocolate or
whatever because it's like i can
procrastinate until 30 minutes before
like their birthday you know is over and
i could push this button and still be a
great friend uh so let me do that you
know that's a great idea machine
noah kagan for my birthday gifted me
like 200 bucks worth of 16 ounce bottles
of topo chico from costco and i like
that was it was like it was easy it was
like a month and a half supply of topo
chico and it's like all i drank for two
and a half months or something it was
awesome yeah on your birthday i tried to
see like is there such a thing as gas
station gift cards but they used to it
was really tough to find anything that
would work
yeah
that's so funny i was like can i open a
tab in my friend's name at your
gas station
deliver time to time yeah
you guys still dip and like yeah cooks
your kids some nacho cheese
[Laughter]
if he brings his own cup can he just
walk out with some hot cheese
that's awesome that's disgusting that's
the episode that's dude you you really
did carry that episode that was amazing
this is this is this entire episode is
going to be called the sampar special
and uh it's just sam bringing hit after
hit after hit you want to know those
quads to work you want to know what i'm
most proud about guess how long uh that
took me to prepare
i think you would be proud if you spent
a long time like 45 minutes oh that went
the other way it's one pm now we started
recording at noon i block off on my
schedule from 11 to noon as my research
time i did all of this in that one hour
time and i even took a bathroom break
and i definitely did some pull-ups so
yeah did you like take the limitless
pill how did you do all that in like 45
minutes
uh i just got a good brain i don't know
i just
yeah i just my brain's good i just was
on fire today i drank a bunch of coffee
nice but that's it we're out of here
[Music]
you